ja geil so leute angriff auf die beatles
die habe ich nämlich vorhin schon alle
aufgeregt sie in paar im livestream und
ich bin darüber geflogen auf einmal
schießen nämlich ab alter und jetzt
kommt meine rache so ich stelle jetzt
nämlich auch auf aber jetzt können ja
quasi mir
ich bin wieder zurück gekommen ohne dass
ich gestorben als ich habe echt so
schlechte erfahrungen im netz dann nicht
nur mega projekt technisch sondern auch
allgemein wo ich damals immer minecraft
gespielt habe immer wenn ich gestorben
wenn es mal immer in etwa so jetzt die
wasserladungen sind da zack zack zack
zack zack zack und jetzt auch [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] scheiße ich brauche dich sonst geht
alles kaputt gerade gibt die kommission
schnell schnell
und zwar muss ich ja genau das mache ich
das wird gerade alles rausgekickt weil
in das gelbe sollst rein in das gelbe
sollst rein in das gelbe soll's rein
durch das weiße sollst durch durch das
grüne solltest durch durch das grüne
sollst durch und durch das grüne sollst
dich so die ganze blöcke die jäger
daneben geflogen sind die dürfte da
dürfte gleich eigentlich nichts mehr
daneben fliegen
ich brauche jetzt nur erstmal ein
minimum stone und zwar sehr schnell und
er schon fast abgenutzt egal ich packte
ihn erst mal hier rein so einfach so mal
eben
außerdem muss ich jetzt nämlich hier
rein tun und ich brauche noch ein für
das rezept scheiße alter [ __ ] ich breche
das erst mal ganz kurz ab dass das hier
alles 21 grad daneben fliegt aber das
ist erstmal egal
und zwar der mini um sound der in dem
auto crafting table geht der kann nicht
kaputt gehen
der ist einfach nur so drin das heißt
ich muss jetzt noch warte 12345 minimum
stones kräften wie mache ich mir da noch
mal mini umstadt alter so viele scherben
und erinnerte dann hab ich dich hab
nicht für viele scherben mensch dann
funktioniert die ganze farben eigentlich
auch erst mal gar nicht mag man daran
habe ich als gar nicht gedacht bevor ich
dass du alles erfüllt habe scheiße und
darf die gerade die ganzen items rum
scheiße wisst ihr was ich clown mir
gleich einfach von ihnen wenngleich die
sachen ich brauche 5 ich habe 16
das sind 8 ich habe für zwei das heißt
ich brauche 24 mio
links ich gebe einfach jetzt spark und
also schreibe ich ihn nachher im skype
und stoppte wird das erlauben oder so
aber wo hat er denn sein lager überhaupt
als jetzt die als megas komisch an hier
minimum ist irgendwas mit mini mini mini
um egal sonst gehe ich im zugriff
leute das ist jetzt nicht stehlen das
ist einfach nur ein nettes leyen
er kriegt ja alles zurück ich weiß noch
nicht wie ich mini um kriege zu einem
mini um scherbe wo ist einfach solche
zerquetscht so leute ab rein hier hat
auch ein bisschen was gemacht hier keine
million hat auch fast nichts auf 24
milliarden menschen müssen die auch
darin liegen alter hast du das ist eine
rolle die er gemacht hat
hier ist sterben zaubern
jeder hat auch links vom mini umstadt
krieg kann ich mir nicht in die mini um
satte schaden kann ich nicht irgendwie
kriegen
scheiße wer könnte das dennoch haben
jetzt gameplay könnte das heim komme
könnte das haben hatte er doch sein haus
wieder aufgebaut stimmt übrigens hier
der krater gefüllt von wenig muss ich
sagen es kann doch nicht sein dass
niemand mini um scherben hat 16 32 ich
schreibe ihnen einfach mal mit schild
gleich am ende der aufnahme so 32 habe
ich jetzt schon mal
ich brauche aber noch welche ich schaue
mal bei bestes denn eigentlich kpt sich
das kgv bei sonic hier vorbei bzw das
gameplay dreh dich mal um die viel etwas
zu wenig
so hatten der nochmal der das soll in
die unterirdisch oder aber wie kommt man
denn da rein bestimmt nur mit dem
portable holder so habe ich jetzt auch
mal kräftig mal das fräsen kam hamm hamm
haben kampf am kampf kampf kampf kampf
kampf kampf kampf
so brocken sams brauche ich gar nicht
erst nach gucken
ich gucke bell simon versteht hier
stimmten wir aus von denen betreten
verboten
der 1
[ __ ] ich will da nicht rein das ganz
dunkel und ich komme nicht mehr raus
geil killer meine portugal nicht mit ja
kommuniziert
lass mich mal durch
brain force dorsten brain force tor
ich gucke einfach mal bei simon nach
rumänien
der muss doch irgendwelche mini ursachen
haben oder als ob die alle nichts haben
davon
sauber zu schauen ich lese nicht
zauberzeit
hier sowie viel brauche ich brauchte
glaube ich warte warte warte
es kommt gleich ich brauche 8 mal 5
also 40 ja ich hab jetzt genau so gut
ich schreib dir das einfach nach und gab
dann muss ich nicht noch ein schild
kraft dann geht die aufnahme auch nicht
mehr so lange sind wir sind mittlerweile
schon im zweiten paar dieser aufnahme
session vielleicht das alles
wahrscheinlich teilen werde gehe ich
aber erstmal runde penan who
das ist echt anstrengend die ganze zeit
einfach so durch zureden und die ganze
zeit produktiv zu sein das ist echt tui
jetzt haben wir minimums dingsbums wir
brauchen noch den inhalt down dafür
brauchen wir stören und gold wir
brauchen fünf also ein zwei drei vier
fünf
das heißt 20 und schon auf 20
so so
26 davon
manchmal das mal hier ich glaube da geht
es doch automatischer da ist automatisch
an den ob der stadt dramatisch tisch
gefragt
dies nicht damit
so so
so also gerechnet habe ich richtig aber
ich hoffe mal dass klubs
ich hoffe mal das stimmt jetzt auch mit
mit meinen berechnungen hier dass das
funktioniert mit der farm
hier muss definitiv einer rein und hier
auch da muss keiner rein weil da ist
doch hier muss so muss das du verdammter
päderast es wieder hingekriegt so hier
muss eine rein und hier
und dann muss hier noch eine reine sich
abnutzt und ich hab ich jetzt ne menge
sex scheiße
sorry jungs tut mir leid ich vergessen
muss er noch eine pipe dran so schauen
wir ob das ganze jetzt funktioniert also
hier werden die koppel stones generiert
die pfeifen durch die golden park durch
in den auto crafting table wo aus den
ball was den global stones links wird
der nutze ich immer weiter ab wo aus
diesen teilen hier blind wird der flint
saust hierdurch in dieses ding da wir
dann klar raus aus den links pumps aus
dem play werden hier claim blöcke und
daraus wird eisen und da ist es
funktioniert denke ich wir warten
einfach noch bis gleichen block kommt
und dann müsste es eigentlich alles
funktioniert und vor allem wir müssen
uns nie wieder darum kümmern das läuft
jetzt einfach so weiter das ist ja das
geile an der ganzen sache
ich würde am liebsten ein bisschen was
rein packen
weil diese ganzen stacks will ich auch
gern dazu verarbeitet haben aber ich
könnte auch einfach mal hier noch so
eine kiste dran stellen wartet das macht
eigentlich auch gar kein problem und
zwar stellte ich jetzt einfach noch mal
so eine doppel kiste mit den ganzen
cobblestone den ich habe dran damit dass
dann auch nochmal rhein gepumpt wird
einfach jetzt so während ich dann hier
so ein bisschen rum mit rolle und so
also die ganze sache hier sehe ich erst
mal in den irgendwann firma neue kiste
gipfel etwas seltenere sachen hier egal
so so das erste komplett dahin du kommst
da kommt die axe dark und erschwert ihr
am besten wenn ich mir die kiste ganzen
sachen aus der kiste in eine andere
kiste punkte und dann mache ich mir den
diamant kiste dafür einfach die mach mir
da noch ein diamant ihr stehe eine bäume
eine jazz sang man einfach seine chest
gold ist also eine art test mit gold
drum
die ist ja genau mit gold g/t gold acht
stück 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ich zähl immer falsch bzw ich klicke und
zähle in verschiedenen rhythmus deswegen
erzähle ich mich dabei immer
beziehungsweise per klick in lich
du kommst da rein da kommt ihr gold fest
so wie geht es jetzt weiter
zwei diamanten und glas alles hat mit
lars zu tun
ich habe auch nur noch zwei diamanten
alter scheiße moment 13 13 13 13
sondern am besten diamant kiste und
schwarz darf
möchtest du hier so und da soll jetzt
die sachen rhein gepumpt werden deswegen
dem ich jetzt einfach mal einen
goldtransport papier wollen dass er
nachher wieder ab scheiße ich kann nicht
oder wir müssen den umweg gehen da
kommen leute machen jetzt einfach mal
den umweg des umwegs alter so die geht
jetzt hier laden hier lang
damit er irgendwo mit in verbindung
kommt hier außenrum die kunden bleibt
zurück so so so so so so
jetzt muss jetzt eine wurden transport
pin weil die orange punkten sollen dann
firma so und jetzt brauche ich noch eine
engine eigentlich pumpen die sachen
daraus welche zu faul bin dass selbst zu
machen
jung ich bin so ein stück scheiße alter
verbrennen sollte man mich da kommst du
lebst du kommst nicht da war ich kurz
davor das so abzubauen
du kommst dahin
funktioniert das ja geil sie war also
ein schwert drin so leute so
funktioniert das wenn man keinen bock
hat die sachen von einer kiste eine
andere zu tun dann macht man das alles
einfach mit zum dingsbums läuft auf
jeden fall bei mir
sodann fügte ich nur da wollen so du
musst noch da waren davon noch einmal
ihr papa ich jetzt mal alle wertvollen
sachen rein wird von mir da hier noch so
ein bisschen diamond armor so ist hier
noch irgendwas drin was war schwerer
fand firma herr die wut gesamtes glas
noch irgendwas die köpfe sind wertvoll
jungclaus dann ist auch wertvoll
hier ist nix wert vom tisch ich weiß
nicht wie ich den cf sprayer benutzer
bzw wie ich den auflade von daher komme
hier wieder der punkt jeden einzelnen
bloß dann von daher statt so langsam von
firma ja
hier kommt hier rein die blume ich
einfach mal hier rein
ja ich werde bald mal so alles sortieren
keine sorge jungs dort werde ich schon
noch machen unter komplett anderen weg
er komme ich jetzt mal die ganze scheiße
jetzt eben hier die kiste hat dies voll
geil
die hühner
ich wollte mir eigentlich meine farm
machen kommt egal ist einfach meine
ganzen fehler hier trifft die ganze crew
aber das war nicht die kuh das war wie
heißt immer rotkohl rotkohl habe ich die
genannt seine partei will behält
ich könnte ja mal sowas wie weit ist in
der jetzt überhaupt erst auf jeden fall
dabei dass daraus zu pumpen soll ich ihm
helfen
also ist ja irgendwas wertvolle strand
von firma herr junge planespotter alter
warum nicht direkt so ein paar das nicht
von anderen silva wurde ließ auch nicht
so spies zum verzaubern musik ist
einfach so viele eier die größe die es
gibt
so rot braun hinbekommt nachfolger zum
nachahmen fackeln sind kann ich auch
eigentlich malereien sind jetzt zwar
nicht so wertvoll aber auf jeden fall
dass man die da rein tun könnte crafting
beiseite mit einem crafting table so die
sachen ja endlich jetzt auch mal weil
ich habe da immer so viele sachen dann
aber nun flinten scheiße so dass ich
noch drin so lapislazuli to play
fix der rest ist relativ wertvoll pisten
das tier generator desch das habe ich
wohl das klar drin
dieser ganze was ist ein ende polders
der egal
und die habe ich dann die ganzen sachen
so von wegen so ärzte und was wisst ihr
das scanner darin alte und tanks nur was
soll ich mit taxen oder obsidian gehört
eigentlich auch in die andere kiste so
kannst du einpacken tanks einfach mal
rein bringt das was wenn ich das ja
nicht mal hier ausgesorgt wir dort heißt
extractor geht auch nicht kompressor
geht ordentlich regnet angst machen
alter ich habe davon so wenig und da
kann man einfach nichts mitmachen das
kann manchmal finden tanks tenor
ja geil gibt es nicht cool
naja lasse ich einfach mal links
kommendes jahr in den scanner der scannt
einem jahr wie viel rost alanya sind
hier drin so fahren hier ist fertig
jetzt kommt mein plan erst mal und zwar
ich brauche feile und ein bogen firma so
ich schau jetzt einfach mal ob das geht
was ich mir denke ich hoffe es geht ich
bin mir nicht sicher
los los los um laufe ich einfach alter
das viel schneller schneller
luca lauf lauf luca wenn ich oben sollte
nämlich nicht treffen oder ja geil so
leute angriff auf die beatles die habe
ich nämlich vorhin schon alle aufgeregt
beziehungsweise in paar im livestream
und ich bin darüber geflogen auf einmal
schießen nämlich ab alter und jetzt
kommt meine rache so ich stelle jetzt
nämlich auch auf aber jetzt können ja
quasi miert alter ich will nichts kaputt
machen hier habe ich will den so ein
bisschen trollen so so so so so so so so
stellte man so dahin soll das denn jetzt
diese mittel nicht auf mich fokussiert
also das ist das geil der hat da oben
auch sein dass radio immer noch stehen
was ich da hingestellt hat hey alter ich
war schon
warum krieg ach so ja gut wenn ich vom
so einfach ist das natürlich klar
ich dachte schon ich bau dir ab so ich
kann ich nicht aufnehmen die strecke
sein haus ab ich keine eltern zu hören
ich komme auch nicht mehr drauf
hallo ja geil was soll jetzt gehts
connecting befördern
ich drehe april statt
ich würde jetzt echt gerne hier drauf es
geht nichts mehr sonst sonst wenn du
wenn ihr interniert sich drauf komme
dann würde ich sagen ich muss sich
beeilen weil sonst die sponti terrazas
so mein internet ist komplett weg weil
skype beendet sich auch gerade ja gut
dann macht mal ganz kurzen stopp wir
sehen schlecht ab so läutet wir wieder
dort erwartet wird wieder das ja mein
internet ist wieder da ja geil also beim
nächsten die manchmal so immer alle drei
vier stunden bricht das kurz ab da muss
die verbindung trennen und ein
multimilliardär verbinden und dann bin
ich wieder daheim also auch das radio
gibt jetzt so dass die tore für die
stelle jetzt auch so auf die gönner
ziemlich alt beziehungsweise dann träume
mal ein bisschen debitor und er etwas so
verdient alter wie kann man hier dann so
viele tore zu stellen und ich
verschwende für diesen scheiß auch noch
meine ganzen eine ganze weile
so dass die nächste und dich auch noch
überhaupt
so herr wo ist die dinge fallen hier
standort so hier kommt eine hin
die stelle ich hier hin und ich stelle
ich ihren so wanders alle ich glaub das
war okay leute rache beziehungsweise
erster schlag gegen debitor ist geglückt
was er denn hier geburt doch das ist
sondern ein handschlag oktober nach der
dauer und auch noch welche idee dass
ladys kommt das erste mal als ich bin
auch im wasser mega schnell so was
wollen wir denn jetzt hier bei bei
broken sams machen
bei broken sams wir könnten ja
theoretisch da könnt mir mal echt fies
sein weil die haben das verdient
die haben mich so oft getötet und zwar
wenn man da rein fällt und man läuft
hier rum läuft immer kurve und sagen wie
feldrain de samba brocken fans fällt
dann mache ich eine druckplatte in und
tnt
das ist ja nicht was viel was hier
kaputt geht dass er fast nichts so
sodann kräften uns eben die druckplatte
ich weiß dass hier auf dem server mit
dnt ist nicht mehr sooo geil aber ich
meine dass ein kleine sachen und ich es
keine news von daher schüttelt und
kümmert sich auch wieder alles aufgebaut
und das riesenpenis das machen wir auch
noch eben schnell und ich wollte auch
eigentlich noch ein radio kräften aber
radio kraft ist bei antwort so viele
ressourcen das ist mir das ist mir toll
einfach nicht wert unterschätzte goma
einfach ein radio das war ein debitor
weil die mieter dann zweimal
ich muss einmal schildern stellen
schilder hat auf jeden fall geklappt
mein plan soll die tories einfach
abzuschießen
was soll ich machen ich wollte einer
druckplatte mitnehmen habe ich nicht und
ich habe mir nie ne platte gemacht
altern läuft bei mir erwarte dafür
brauche ich ein 2
und tnt habe ich mir auch noch nie
gemacht
norbert n t
camcorder und sand und und und und
ich hab mir immer alles sofort wieder
verarbeitet ich bin so ein penner
ich muss irgendwann mal so eine tour
machen wo ich einfach in der wüste gehe
und mir sand ohne ende hole so da habe
ich meine vier sind so daneben dass die
mittel stellt das zukomme und dann haben
wir das ein bisschen geträumt einsamer
tod warnte game
ach ja wer den wollte ich auch noch was
machen jetzt habe ich auch schon gedacht
na egal was soll ich machen
tnt ich bin seehofer teilt gerade nach
meinem internet abschluss habe ich so
viel getrunken als ich das ganze wasser
steckt mein gehirn und meine
gehirnzellen vexeo.de und jetzt wird
auch noch brocken samstag rollt und dann
das radio von debitor muss ich auch noch
mitnehmen dann schreibe ich einfach zu
debitor schöne torres hast du conny
wenn ich im flieger dank diesen key so
dass sie nicht mit
und hier vor
er wird wahrscheinlich in seinem keller
seien nähe der wenn er abgeschossen wird
dann wird er versuchen rauszugehen
dann schreibe ich hier einfach hin
schöne tore
hast du da stehen
conny nikon crafter vielleicht hilft
nämlich unter dem pseudonym kontinent
schöne jarretts hast du da stehen von
crafter so dass radio hab ich
eingesammelt stell dich jetzt zukomme
und eine platte bei dem im gebäude weil
dann merkt er dass nicht bzw
der hört die musik und regt sich dann
auf und bleib ich glaube dass direkt
vorstellen dahin einfach so
das ist sowohl gott verdammt nervig da
kommt die links drauf schöne musik in
deinem haus
und jetzt noch zu brocken fans
schön rüber pflegern ab vielleicht löst
es auch weh wie aus aber wenn er wieder
zuerst rein geht an die sind beide auf
der gamescom
ich glaub broken wings ist er zuhause
schöner tunnel
conny
so das gleiche noch mal auf die andere
seite und dann kommt hier
das tnt hin
er funktioniert das überhaupt
ja oder so
wenn wir nicht an welchen übelster fällt
ob der tunnel sieht ja noch schön aus
sieht schön aus
conny jetzt weil der es ist lol ich habe
ein 50 zentimeter pimmel nein spaß
60 so dann setze ich mir auch erst
blocken recht einfach so fertigt
wirklich nicht geschützt aber plötzlich
im juni teilte das ist ein fall fliegt
männer so leute das war als wir ein
bisschen geträumt werden reisen vom
hingekriegt die am laufen müsst ihr
schon es ist gleich mal an was steht der
brücke verschönern lüftchen modellbau
wie die japaner besteht darin denkmal
für wenig kraft dass ich hier so richtig
klein geredet hat seinen gebrochenen
schwanz alter ich freue mich so auf
gamescom wahrscheinlich war ich schon
längst nicht mehr vergehens kommt so als
wieder perfekt bei mir sport ball mehr
als ein paar läuft die zeit mal gucken
wie schnell das geht ok geht jetzt aber
wenn ich zum beispiel tag warten würde
dass man jetzt zehn minuten glaube ich
welchen tag wartet dann habe ich dann
locker mehrere sex eisen drin und dann
brauche ich nicht mehr fahren gehen das
funktioniert ja alles ich könnte jetzt
noch eine sterling engine dran hatte
läuft er ist ja funktioniert alles läuft
auf jeden fall also eisenbach
hingekriegt und wir haben geträumt und
ja freuen wenn es euch gefallen hat und
ihr mehr von so was waldbad ist es hier
völlig nieder das kommt noch
ausstehenden nachgekommen so sieht
mittlerweile beiden grundstück aus also
es geht mehr in richtung technik wenn es
euch gefallen hat will ich mich wirklich
über eine bewertung freuen wenn euch
solche sachen gefallen produktiv aber
auch mit rollen dann gebt einfach einen
daumen hoch vielleicht schaffen wir
irgendwie weiß nicht 1000 2000 oder so
das wäre schon hammer und schreibt mir
eine kommentare was ich als nächstes
trollen soll beziehungsweise als
nächstes bauen soll technik mäßig und
eventuell auch eine zauberin
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
ich mache gerade einen schlag meine fans
kämen die gar nicht vorhanden ist
aber egal gelegt